for Seattle is exam please all
Washington is going to say is peace I'm
still the the Midwest is where concern
is yep no doubt about that so if if we
do that then we are at 239 to 232 Trump
to 209 Hillary Clinton and now Florida
has been called for Donald Trump
officially so that is starting to close
the window for Hillary Clinton uh
while while yeah that's something isn't
it that is this huge man it's a hate I
don't want to use that word ever again
yeah but it's it's very significant um
there's gonna have to be a it not to say
that it's over right the hope what would
Sam say hope springs eternal I will see
what happens but there's gonna have to
be a huge autopsy of this election to
see what yeah
tire f happened here I will say and the
trumpeters are in a tizzy over this I
mean they're going to be pleasuring
themselves to this video from today for
probably years to come yeah uh that I
think we can all agree with agree about
well but it does put us in a position
where anything that happens in America
anything wrong that happens becomes
theirs they own it they own it and uh
it's it's always easiest to uh win after
someone else has been in office right to
have to have three uh to have three
consecutive presidents of uh uh two
terms brock obama and eighty years and
since it happier that's a stretch it is
a stretch
it is a stretch indeed and this is where
when we if you had looked at the
predictions that base predictions on uh
sort of like the environment not the
individual candidates but the
environment and who's been in power and
etc those pointed to trump and we just
were saying to ourselves well but the
guy's so clueless that i'm sure that
that has to be a factor but no those
predictions seem to have have been
correct and and i think soon I think if
Wisconsin or Michigan go Trump even
though mathematically it won't be over
it will be for all practical purposes
override it does anybody disagree that
if Wisconsin or Michigan go Trump now
that Florida is officially for Trump but
were were basically wrapping up
I I agree uh I don't really see a path
for Hillary yeah
without Wisconsin in Michigan yeah I'm
sure once that result comes in
they won't officially call it for them
because we just won't be in that
position yet yeah but for unto all
intents and purposes
it'll be over I think you're right about
that uh let's let's go back and take a
couple more calls just to see what's
going on let's take the call from 904
904 a named town and topic please
Jacksonville yet what we can barely hear
you but you are on I don't know if we
can turn them up at all Pat yeah go
ahead that better yeah it's better hey
you
my name is hearth and I'm calling from
Florida which was just uh unfortunately
kin to trump yes it was um it wasn't all
right I know it was it was absolutely
right that has gone to trump and
Michigan will be going to Trump soon I
think from what we're seeing then yeah
good yeah I'm keeping up with that arm
two quick questions um from an outside
from like a European or the rest of the
world looking down on this election yeah
and how it's going right now how do you
think they are viewing this presidential
election right now they are calling this
as in its absolute unexplainable
disaster right I mean people I I know
you know I have family in France I have
plenty of family in Argentina I have
family in Israel I have a lot of friends
in Italy nobody knows what the hell is
going on they thought it was a joke how
could this possibly be real when I would
talk to them as during the primaries
they'd say hey with this funny thing
about this Trump guy running right I
mean it it is nothing that is believable
to people outside of the US it's barely
believable to people in the u.s. I don't
know how else to describe it it seems
like a joke
am I the only thing I could think that
they would think is that this is a some
type of trend that we're seeing globally
yeah with Briggs it and of course
they're gonna try to tie into it yeah
but you know there's always going to be
ignorant and bigotry true and um you can
call s people around it you can easily
call s people around hate uh and I'm
sorry she goes what's the slogan love
Trump's hate yeah not unless you work
super
art yet otherwise eight is the easiest
emotion to capitalize on yep I agree
with you thank you so much for the call
I really appreciate it all right
and one more thing okay well I'm only at
many different numbers on uh political
I'm not sure paper should fall so to go
right now
I what would I was nothing different I'm
looking at the political website and I'm
looking to like go vote that each have
and I just see different numbers way
different numbers from there's you're
like they're looking at Trump right now
having uh two hundred thirty two
electoral votes I'm not sure if I should
continue that what we have we also have
two thirty two for Trump so I all right
yeah we agree on that
all right thanks very much for the call
we are getting close to another
projection I am I am hearing and will be
able to call something else
I am scared to say maybe Wisconsin for
Donald Trump and if that is the case
then we're breaking out the beers uh I
think that that uh that is going to be
the way it goes uh let's stand by for
that and we can let's let's put our our
map up for the time being and just sort
of look at what those scenarios would be
uh is though weed weed is legal in
Massachusetts now that what to check on
that did that one here yeah so okay if
Wisconsin goes Trump that would get him
to 242 but more importantly it would
make the path for Hillary Clinton much
more difficult if instead it is Michigan
that gets called for Trump that puts
Trump at 2:48 again not a game ender for
Hillary Clinton but certainly not very
good and we're just waiting for what
this projection is going to be uh let's
go over to our map their hypothetical
map where we have Pennsylvania for
Hillary Clinton if Wisconsin and
Michigan go for Trump then in the
realistic map it's basically over even
with Pennsylvania for Hillary Clinton
because of what Donald Trump is likely
to win this is with Minnesota for
Hillary Clinton this is even with Nevada
for Hillary Clinton which may actually
end up with Trump and you would have to
89 what this is shaping up for is a very
tight race let's switch to the actual
map the projection is that Hillary
Clinton is one Washington which we
already had we were
that press so no surprise there and does
not change our map but now a lot of the
networks are sort of catching up with us
um Wisconsin Michigan those are going to
be really really tough let's see if
there's anything else that is called
here um no nothing else is going to be
called here and we are at uh we believe
232 to 209 some of the networks have
Trump and 216 because they've not yet
given him Georgia we have given Trump
Georgia yeah and but we believe that it
is only a matter of time until the
networks do uh what are we waiting for
here banner is it is it just that last
one um which Wisconsin or Michigan and
that really is going to tell us the
direction this is going I mean at that
point Wisconsin and Michigan uh what was
a synod the the Senate race in Wisconsin
that uh Russ Feingold and I think he was
down big yet of losing he ended uh
Johnson I don't know first name yeah
Bron Johnson I believe and if you
checked 538 beforehand uh Johnson only
had an eighteen percent chance of
winning whoa yeah this is this is uh the
trajectory of all the races it seems
will happen with God's event that's we
need to do we need to dig down into the
data for Wisconsin to see what the hell
happened there cuz that's phenomenal
even see uh in in New Hampshire and in
Florida well he took Florida which but
it was closer right arm
he took Florida Marco Rubio took Florida
that seems consistent but in New
Hampshire uh Donald Trump took uh as
well we haven't closed out New Hampshire
yet now Wow okay so it's just seen that
the the Senate races are splitting uh
are potentially splitting but um
Wisconsin this is uh this is a big
surprise here yeah Wisconsin now a three
point four percent lead for Donald Trump
and then let's just just to see just to
be thorough let's see what the latest
Michigan numbers are because it had
close to 0.5 but I am worried it is now
back up to one point one percent in
favor of Donald Trump with 64% reporting
Michigan is isn't Michigan notoriously
slow on on counting alit's yeah that's
my recollection every every election
cycle they are slow yeah
and if back in New Hampshire Kayla kelly
ayotte the Republican she's back in the
lead so uh it would be interesting to
see if that splits goes to the Senate
goes to the Republican Party yeah and
the electoral votes goes to Hillary
Clinton we'll see